i saw a protest i was going out to get
you know coffee or whatever in the
morning and they were saying it was one
of those things where it was like uh men
can have children too
about men can have babies too and i was
like okay it was a protest that like uh
yeah they do a thing where like you know
the people that say men can't have
babies are like you know disrespect are
like they're transfo all these things
they're terrorists you know
it's a big thing college kids believe
that men can have babies because they
mean uh do they mean a female that
transitioned to a male yes so but they
are saying they still have their female
organs so they can biologically have a
baby that's what they're saying what's
saying it's possible here
uh robert winston um a pioneer of in
vitro fertilization and cigarettes told
london sunday times that
told london sunday times that male
pregnancy would certainly be possible by
having an embryo implanted in a man's
abdomen with the placenta attached to an
internal organ such as the bowel
oh that and then if you're pregnant you
can say i'm having bowel movements
whoa wait but so man can get pregnant i
don't understand what
to make all right tomorrow nashville me
and sally babes the ryman auditorium
then march 18th i'm in seattle 19th
portland march 25th las vegas nevada and
just real quickly i have my second
comedy special coming out at youtube.com
christy comedy sometime in late march so
subscribe now i'm very very proud of it
directed by the homeless pimp if you're
watching this on march 10th
march 11th in nashville chrissy march
12th at chattanooga then we're going
april 15th and 16th louisville and
evansville april 23rd and 24th
tulsa and oklahoma city and then we got
may 14th at the beacon and may 21st and
22nd san diego and la salvocano
be a comedy.com don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe
you think you got it oh you think you
got it but gotta just don't get it when
there's nothing at all
here
what's up baby how you doing god bless
god bless baby look at this
i like this sweatshirt thank you so much
this is uh it's comfy it's in the merch
store now is also the new york cubans
your merch no
i got this as a gift
i got this was that a real gift
what was that a real life it was when
yes well back in the day day so one of
the original babies he said it was negro
leagues i think maybe and they were
called the cube but that doesn't make
sense right yeah because it's cuba right
unless so we named them after cigars i
don't know i don't know we could google
them where's the new york cubans from
where are the new york cubans from what
where are the new york cubans what where
new york cuban's name come from or
whatever there it is
new york cuba's negro league baseball
team that played during the 1930s and
from 1939 to 1950 shout out oh they
played at tony hinchcliffe stadium wow
and the polo grounds
um do you have us do you smoke cigars or
no i don't i tried i can't get into it i
don't know how to not inhale let me ask
you how do you not inhale go ahead ask
me i've never smoked a scar in my life
in your life i've attempted no and they
say you got to cut off the end of it i'm
like what do we have to circumcise the
cigar for you i don't know what's going
on my people my friend plenty of friends
of mine go to cigar lounges yeah it's
not appealing to me my clothes stink no
it's not i don't want to be in there at
all like i'm in the middle of a fire
what a coveted nightmare cigar lounge
right just blowing into each other's
faces coughing
pimp you ever smoked a cigar
no i just just weed just weed i've i've
i've felt myself missing out because i
didn't know how to smoke like i've been
at events with people and i just
everyone likes a cigar and they're all
like ah
like you know like even birds but like
oh cigar i'm like i don't know i don't
do things that most like
men like we're getting to the age now
where it's like we should be doing
things like our dads did like men's
stuff like i don't smoke cigars i don't
play golf i don't know how to barbecue
yeah i don't know how to fix anything i
don't know how to carve a thanksgiving
turkey
i'm not a real guy we are identical
yeah identical babe does it bother you
like i don't know how to smoke i golf
not good but i have golfed but it's not
good i i've got i've got like maybe once
a year for the last 20 years but let me
let me ask you this if somebody said hey
you know we want to golf you know we'll
come to the golf uh range whatever come
to the course big business meeting
we're gonna go okay the range is just
hitting balls it's of no consequence but
if i had to go in there with people that
can golf yeah i'm shanking half of my
shots because i like because andrew
santino told me the great andrew santino
um the red rocket he's a part of a
pretty you know like premier golf
place yeah golf what are they called
golf clubs
country club in um in la and he said
like literally the better you are at
golf like the better you can go in your
career because because if you stink at
golf they look at you like i don't want
to be around this person so you got to
know golf well i'm not necessarily
hanging out with those people right but
the last person i golfed with is mariana
rivera that's pretty good and he was
good
he's good man he's good right the first
game he ever got in his life he beat his
friend who took him golfing who was a
golfer does that make sense yes well no
it doesn't but yeah but i would assume
that marion rivera can win at anything i
was on his team we were playing teams we
were playing like i think it's called
like long ball or whatever in a
tournament for his charity yeah and he
was on my team and it was a par three i
don't know if you know anything about
golf there's a par three meaning you
have to have three shots to get in into
the hole or else you start you get
negative points yeah correct okay no it
was uh sorry it was a par four and he
drove it so far
that it was on the green in one
which is so hard to do it was it was far
it was a big green but i would and i had
to putt and so i was putting for two
under par which is an eagle which is
like
crazy rare right
maybe i wasn't even that far from the
hole really but anyway i sunk it why
don't we got an eagle but you think that
i'm not a bad person because i don't
know about golf no you're a bad person
other reasons god yes
because i don't know how to golf i don't
know how to bowl i know you know how to
bowl no i don't know i thought you were
really oh i know how to bowl like anyone
knows that you pick up a ball and you
roll it you look like if i didn't know
you and you gave me one guess as to what
your profession was i would say he owns
a bowling alley
no way that would be my pimp do you get
it
but a good one a really fun one like one
that's really like i'd say you're a
multi-million dollar bowling bowling
alley owner but i don't understand why
imagine we just started doing things we
asked each other extremely personal
questions like what's the most money
ever had in your bank account
um let people send in those questions
and we gotta answer them just be it yeah
um
dude speaking of smoking cigars do you
have you ever vaped
well not vape cigarettes but vaped weed
do you understand that vaping i do not
know i guess it's called vaping right
the pen
uh wnba star superstar britney grineer
is in russian prison right now she may
go to jail for years because she had
vape card she's in her bag my question
to you guys is like i've never vaped but
people vape like isn't that an easy
thing to like forgets in your bag like
she wasn't trying to smuggle and vape i
forget it in every bag i have so so my
question to you is if you
if i if i just said pick up your bags
we're going to russia yeah and you went
in and you went into highly likely that
you have truthfully a vape cartridges in
your bag and you'd be in prison for 15
years no that's what they're saying
grineer is going to go to jail
potentially because now obviously what's
happening with the with the war in
russia and all that they're not
negotiating with the united stand then
they're not talking to the us like
there's no extra dish they're like no
she enrolled
she's a russian uh a lot of the wnba
players in the offseason they play
professional basketball in other
countries so she's playing in russia but
with everything that was going down
maybe she didn't think to take those
cartridges out of her bag but i think
she was trying to come back to the
america i think she was targeted because
they knew like she was i think that she
was i think honestly what happened was
she she left and she she was nervous so
she was
vaping to calm her down and she forgot
they were in a bag and you know that's
what happened you're telling me that she
might go to jail for 15 years that's
what they're saying first for a
substance that's legal here that it
doesn't matter a russian prison russian
prison yep
um
yeah 15 years or maybe they're putting
given her 15 years because she's gay i
don't know russia would do that they
seriously would like i don't know or
maybe because she's a woman even yeah
she's a gay woman or maybe
maybe because she's a basketball player
yeah or maybe because she's an american
yeah she could get five years for every
one of those charges every single one of
those charges i love to like i know
we're not it's not a political thing at
all but i love like how the united
states is just being like sanctioning
russia being like you we're not going to
show the mass singer
visa mastercard you can't use your card
we're not going to have tv shows on that
you guys love in russia they're like
shut up just do something real but the
real sanctions are hitting them right
yeah they are they're hitting them right
in the shops they're hitting them right
well they're hanging out in the chops
look at the gas prices five bucks what
can you do you know what's the beautiful
thing about this podcast is we you know
we as you guys know we always film this
podcast you know a little bit a couple
of days before it actually comes out and
the good news is about about the time of
the world we're in right now is you know
there uh we could be nuked by the time
the pod comes out this could be one of
the last transmissions uh the people who
find the remnants of us ever here the
way it's going could you imagine this
was the last thing this this is what
people thought
the world was
how soon until president zielinski from
the ukraine gets a netflix special will
he get who will get one first he's gonna
me or i think i think most ukrainian i
think if if there's a ukrainian comic
they they should just let them know
right now i mean could you imagine being
the president
it's it's it is his story is insane yeah
you know his story now by now if he you
know the
makes a show about being the president
of ukraine that's get then gets elected
of the actual president of ukraine
that's above ukraine by the way i've
been told to stop saying the ukraine
it's ukraine but doesn't doesn't it feel
natural to say the ukraine or you've
never thought to put a in front of no i
do i say i hear the you get the ukraine
i've heard that and i went to a protest
a rally with the ukrainian
ukraine one in uh in chicago
recently yeah last week were you just
were you still i was shut out i was
playing the vic shout out madison
chicago great shows and i went to the
did you ever go to the bean
sure the bean in chicago that i love the
bean that that like shiny i want to talk
about you looking fat bad angles yeah
the beans i took them all everyone there
thinks they're a professional
photographer they're not i'm gonna get
this cool shot i'm gonna get this cool
shot i got it but there was uh a
ukraine rally there and uh we joined and
joined in it was wild it was uh it was
organized but it was it was touching is
it was really tough ukraine ukraine a
lot of people have been like oh you know
you've probably somebody yelled at me on
twitter the other day i said you
probably never even heard heard of
ukraine before this i said i have
because my favorite figure skater of all
time is oscana bayul right and she was
repping ukraine and i was watching this
is it oksana oksgana bayer
here's ready for this here's what it was
it was when i was a kid i used to watch
women's figure skating like it was my
job like whoa like like whoa like i used
to sit down with my mom and pretend i
wasn't a gay child and i would watch
women's figure skating tripod
christy yamaguchi yeah yeah katarina
viet yeah i mean amazing amazing amazing
nancy carrick and tonya all day long all
day pull up women's figure skaters in
the 90s i guarantee i mean there's some
i mean i just feel like every time they
go up for like a triple axel they're
literally going to fall and their leg's
going to pop off pop right off yeah it's
no see i don't want to see any of the
new people the new figures brian boytano
i mean
what would brian boytano do brian
boytano he would do backflips and it was
g and scott hamilton they would do
backflips and brian boytano isn't that a
song
why some south park what would brian
bartano do really yeah
i didn't know that yeah yeah see none of
these people it's i i want to do the 90s
that nine times
was when we were little wasn't she in uh
no that's
that's mark hamill oh no relation no no
relation i don't think so the 90s the
90s figure skaters i can't see that uh
okay who was the best oh nathan chen is
not the best figure skater ever how dare
you
um oh speaking of sanctions you know
what else too
unfortunate bad news that does hit home
sometimes the sanctions hit your family
okay they hit my family a little bit
the the world cat uh federation has
banned russia so unfortunately uncle
russell's cat um
he got a couple of gigs cancelled yes
uncle russell is now unfortunately the
russell the international cat federation
has banned cats with russian owners due
to the ukraine crisis so allegedly that
takes a big big hit
away from you know his world so if
anybody wants to donate to uncle
russell's go to gofundme.com
oh i didn't want to sl what kind of
protester are you are you chanting or
you're just marching
i was there you know like i wasn't like
i wasn't i didn't want to like chant
because like i i'm not
i mean it was like i didn't want to like
you weren't doing it i didn't i didn't
want to impede
on you know
what they were doing and saying but i
did chant i joined along sometimes yeah
what was the chance you remember uh it
was something about the us helping the
ukraine u.s help crane yes it was
something like something like that yeah
you
i took some video you can't spell
ukraine without you that's right
have you ever been to a protest chris at
all or and i why and i yeah
um have i been to a protest
i've walked into them
um
actually in madison wisconsin i was in a
pro i saw a protest i was going out to
get you know coffee or whatever the
morning uh morning after the show
and i saw a protest of
um college kids and they were saying it
was one of those things where it was
like uh men can have children too
about men can have babies too and i was
like okay it was a protest like a yeah
they do a thing where like you know the
people that say men can't have babies
are like you know disrespect are like
they're transfo all these things they're
terrorists you know
it's a big thing college kids believe
that men can have babies
because they do they mean uh do they
mean a female that transitioned to a
male yes so but they are saying they
still have the their female organs so
they can biologically have a baby that's
what they're saying what's saying it's
possible here
uh robert winston um a pioneer of in
vitro fertilization and cigarettes told
london sunday times that
told london sunday times that male
pregnancy would certainly be possible by
having an embryo implanted in a man's
abdomen with the placenta attached to an
internal organ such as the bowel
oh that and then if you're pregnant you
could say i'm having bowel movements
whoa wait but so a man can get pregnant
i don't understand what to make
fertilization
well listen they it's a surgery that
lets the baby feed off your intestines
is that your foul for you or the baby i
would i would guess no
i mean why has it not been done or has
it i mean i don't think that yeah wasn't
there a male pregnant a pregnant male
like a few years ago
they were born a female okay and kept
their
uterus okay and then but not a uh not a
person born with male reproductive
organs that birth cannot have a baby
right
right i mean unless you're not gonna
have a baby on your penis
somehow one day god willing
oh here we go there it is that's the guy
yeah that's the guy this is the guy and
he was a guy that was that was pregnant
i mean that's literally what i look like
with my shirt off
are you having a fat day today
i had a fat day yesterday posing like
demi moore on the cover of vanity fair
did you just see that
uh headline woman gets trapped in cruise
ship watersides splendid over the ocean
that's terrifying how did she get
trapped in there
a female cruise ship pasture was left
high but not dry after getting trapped
in on the attraction's massive water
slide overlooking the ocean
that's
a video of her unorthodox
strand stranding at sea currently boasts
over 15 million views on that's what we
have to do
that's the tick tock no
wait what how is she stuck though why
don't you just go how'd you get stuck
maybe not enough water
yeah but just crawl out
i mean yeah here we go look at this oh
no
oh
no
oh
so so how does she get
do we have like a vacuum how does she
get out oh my god
well they have to definitely dry it
right
she has to be so nervous
i mean wouldn't you be terrified
immediately claustrophobic yeah because
how am i gonna get you out of that
because she can't go up she can't go
back up that's too steep no way so and
you and you're not gonna be able to
how does this woman get out of this
how did she
i mean maybe how has that never happened
before either she didn't even come close
to making it not even close
she was too skinny you see you wanted a
popular song oh yeah this song yeah
these tick tock songs oh no
we play that
oh no i'm gonna have to if she would
have had a little bit more she would
have had him no no no no no
oh no did somebody ring the bell by the
way
i didn't hear that i heard somebody have
an update
yeah what happened to what happened yeah
how do okay the clips okay yeah i love
water slides by the way me too but i
hate water parks
okay catch 22. i love nothing more than
being on the slide i love nothing less
than traipsing about the park you don't
want to be the park no when you walk now
let me ask you are you walking out the
restrooms
are you a water shoe guy
i wasn't in my throughout my life but in
a place like disgusting place like that
i might if i went in recent days i might
have to wear that i'll tell you what i'm
more of a water shoe guy than i am a
flip-flop guy you you'd be you'd have
better luck seeing me in a water shoe
than a flip yeah what kind of flip you
do you do the whole foot goes through
the arch or you do it in between the
toes no because my toes are crossed over
like this so i i have to
it's very humiliating to have to
separate my toes to stick them into the
thong part so i rather just put my foot
but then because my toes are crossed
over like this there is not a sandal i
found that doesn't rub up against the
top and then i get around i get a
blister on the top of my toe so i'm a
water shoe guy i got it i'm a water shoe
guy so what happened thankfully she was
able to exit the slide without
intervention from emergency services how
it says there's a side door
oh they got a figure yeah but didn't she
look that would have been falling to the
ocean yeah
i mean they must have had some kind of
netting or something i don't know
that's wild dude
i would be
terrified there was a time when i got
stuck in an elevator and i it's scary i
got second elevated my apartment
building i was living in
and my laptop i had my laptop with me i
don't know why i brought my laptop down
with me and my laptop was so hot it
started to get so hot and i was stuck in
the elevator for like 20 minutes and i
just kept thinking what if this sets on
fire right and i'm dying a fire
in an elevator were you on your laptop
is that why yeah i had been on it and
then i just closed it down and took the
elevator up and i was stuck in between i
had thought that i was like
suspended in in the air like i thought i
was on the 10th floor which is right
floor was living on i was in between the
first floor in the basement no yeah when
i yeah and they had to come get you out
they had to come get me out the fire
department had to pry open the door like
pry pry it open with like this special
key and i was i couldn't believe like
how stuck i was in there it was
i i was so
so so like beyond afraid i actually
don't like even getting in an elevator
by myself because i'm like if this gets
stuck i feel like even though i know
there's emergency buttons yeah but
there's this panic to be like what if i
never
get out which i know is childish in the
movies they take off a panel on the roof
but i think they're just [ __ ] making
it look easy oh
boys and girls raycon wireless earbuds
are back with the hey babe podcast
yeah raycon wireless earbuds are the
best way to bring audio we feel good
yes i yeah i feel real good ray j ray j
because i'm bringing on wireless earbuds
today because no matter how much you
shake it up literally no matter how much
you shake you know they will not fall
out of your ears and i've tried that
i've put ray bud raycon earbuds in my
ears and i've shaken my head yeah
and they never fall you spend a whole
weekend doing that one that's what i did
they fall in they don't fall out their
everyday earbuds look feel and just
sound better than ever there's also
awareness mode for when you need to
listen to your surroundings ooh i like
that yes so you can take raycons with
you wherever you go with optimized gel
tips for a perfect in-ear fit these
earbuds are so comfortable they will not
budge trust us yes and after ada they
offer eight hours of play time and a
32-hour battery life dude it's the best
right now listeners can get 15 off their
raycon order at byraycon.com
hey babe that's b u y r a y c o n dot
com hey babe say fifty percent on ray
cons buy recon dot com slash hey babe
oh
you know did you learn that language on
babel yes i did you speak in babylon
speaking babylonian listen
bang what language are you hearing what
babel language are you listening to we
love babble babe listen this is a
language learning app that sold more
than 10 million subscriptions so who are
you to say anything about babble when
they got 10 million subscripts easy one
seriously what do you want to do you
want to learn a new language what do you
want to do you want to engage in a new
hobby yeah what do you want to do you
want you want you want to go someplace
and you want to travel more you want to
be able to speak to people when you
travel the whole babble process is
addictively fun fast and easy they teach
you bite-size language lessons for real
world use 15 minutes on the go babes
15-minute lessons get your head out of
your ass that's right and they use real
language experts they do other apps do
not they use a.i for their plans there's
no ai and they they use the languages
like spanish french italian german plus
babel speech recognition technology
helps you improve your pronunciation and
accent there's just so much stuff to do
and ways to learn with babel it's like
podcasts games videos live classes how
about that cute whoa right now when you
purchase a three month babble
subscription you will get an additional
three months free free that's six months
for the price of three just go to
babble.com use promo code hey babe
that's b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com
code hey-bae babble language for life
i think you're screwed if you get in
there yeah i got stuck in once but it
was on purpose they they they fooled me
i got stuck in an elevator on purpose
but they rigged it but i was in there
for about an hour and had no idea what
to do what to say i was with up two
other people and i didn't know that they
were plants one guy had a terrible cold
guys coughing and sneezing all over me
and i actually had words with him really
and then another woman had a cat which i
hate
and the cat was loose and the cat pissed
in the elevator
wow right in front of me and then out of
nowhere it just started to move well
they came and they got the fire
department the fighter pump was working
on it
i thought and they're like banging and
everything and it's all like aren't they
here and then at one point i was like
asking the question and the final was
like uh just don't worry about it like
he answered me like an [ __ ] and i was
like what yeah i was like what did you
just say i was like that's how you guys
talk to us we're trapped in here yeah
and he said something i was like i can't
believe this is how the fire department
is talking to us and then it opened up
of course and i realized that it was all
yo one time i was on the elevator with
my girl who's like a very feisty puerto
rican woman
we had delilah my she was older starter
but she was young at the time she was
maybe
nine months old 10 months old
i'm sorry maybe she was a year old and
we lived in like a very trendy building
in park slope brooklyn it's like very
trendy area of new york city right like
everybody's hipsters and whatever you
know like they're like that and we get
in the elevator it's you know me jazz
and our little daughter and she's in the
stroller she's got the binky on you know
whatever get in elevator stops at the
eighth floor
and this woman like like she looked like
a professor like this like white lady
like professor like you know like one of
those like like a pantsuit no well she
was a white one but she had like
dreadlocks like she was very much like
she looked like i am of every culture
like very like you know the woke and
just like you know a little obnoxious
and she goes in and she looks at the
baby you know which is fine she looks at
her like a little bit like
and then looks at jasmine and jasmine is
just like looking at her with like smoke
coming out of her ears because you know
the thing is is like jazz was always
like don't look at my kid like just
don't even look at my kid and i was like
okay seems reasonable yeah yeah so like
very protective
so i could feel like there was some yes
drama about the start but for no reason
for real was you were looking at was she
looking at your kid with an arrow she
looked at her with an attitude that's
the issue wasn't like oh you get so cute
now you have to say that but she looked
at her like oh so if she was like what
an adorable baby jasmine wouldn't be
like no of course no she looked she
looked at her what what
she looked at her up and down and then
like looked and was like staring at
judges
judgment
and so she says
we uh we're going down
and then she says to jasmine i'm going
down
you ain't around yes
um
so
we're going down the elevator and the
woman turns to jasmine she goes can i
ask you a question she was like how old
is your daughter and jasmine was like
she's one she goes she's all too old for
a binky oh
[ __ ]
yeah
she goes yeah she's too old for a
pacifier ah don't do that and then
jasmine goes i'll do whatever i want
it's my baby's mouth right and then and
then she goes yeah well it's going to
cause she goes i work and child care i
would be like you're too old for
dreadlocks yeah you two also join last
[ __ ] yeah yeah and she goes and she
goes um i work in child care and this is
going to develop bad habits the children
shouldn't have pacifies after eight
months you should do your research
something like that
to god i've never been in a situation
like this
i didn't even know you could do that
that's what she was joking i
[Laughter]
i was that's why i'm bringing this up
because you think be trapped in elevator
that was the one and only time my life
i've been purposely trapped in the
elevator and she jasmine again just very
stereotypically just starts taking out
her earrings like which is what like
latina girls doing who's preparing
they're preparing she goes say something
to me now [ __ ] say something to me now
and i had to like separate them like it
was wild like wild wild wild situation i
hit the emergency
break again you know hit the thing again
it takes like five minutes for it the
fire department is called automatically
when you hit that i get down there
there's all firemen in the lobby tell me
the story of a movie i don't know i just
only thought about it with the elevator
there's all firemen in the lobby
and we come off
and she goes jasmine you know the
firemen are like what what happened are
everyone okay i was like i was like yeah
i was like you know she hit the
emergency brake and she was and the
fireman was like it was like an
old-school older fireman he was like why
would you hit the emergency brake i was
like well
i said this woman right here
told uh jasmine that our child was too
old to have a pacifier
and she goes and you really pissed off
you're welcome
no i still get it he said you know he
said he said you know really i'm
supposed to have give you guys like a
500 fine for you know you pretty much
mess with an alarm he goes i'm not going
to give it to you he goes i mean these
people suck
yeah i know and i was like wow and then
and then that woman never saw that woman
again we told the doorman in the
building and he was like that lady sucks
she fights with everybody yeah
but that one was probably out of protest
isn't it weird that that woman's crazy
woke you're saying she's a white woman
she has dreads she's this she's that
yeah but then honestly if you go even
more woke she's she's uh appropriating
of course she's she's woke she's
she's as well because she thinks there's
no rhyme or reason talks people you if
you think you're walking you're gonna
get out whoa i woke and just like if you
if you want to call somebody out for
their behavior baby you better you
better be mother teresa but eventually
mother teresa had some [ __ ] going down
right of course she did she's human
mother you think about jesus out there
i don't know he's right around that [ __ ]
my eighth grade teacher my eighth grade
teacher was a nun
on one of the last days of eighth grade
we're 13 years old she goes you guys are
gonna you know
kids are gonna go out there into high
school
now and uh you know there may be
decisions that you're faced with um
and you know like just be careful and
you know you know all the things that
we've learned and she goes you know when
i was she goes because when i was my the
summer of my uh year uh my eighth grade
into my uh you know freshman year high
school i i was i got pregnant with a
child and i had to give up that child
and then i became a nun and we were like
yo whoa
sister margaret was out there since
lamar was out there
[ __ ]
bro and she had a nun who had a baby and
did told us on the last day oh wow one
of the last days i didn't know you could
do that what do you mean i didn't know
you could like have a
you know get pregnant and then become
another i don't remember the rules i
know imagine like imagine like on her
none on her none interview like her she
goes with her friend and then they ask
her they ask they ask sister mark like
you've ever had any sexual intercourse
and sister mark goes no and her friend
goes shilon
[Laughter]
she passes those flying colors she gets
an a plus there's like 100 questions and
then they're like my god yeah you are
saint-worthy yeah one last thing yeah
have you ever had intercourse and then
she's like
what's the matter
she goes i never know she goes listen
never vaginally but i have done anal is
that
that's fine nuns do not need to be
virgins vatican announces as pope agrees
holy brides of christ can have sex and
still be married to god
that's a weird thing to call them the
holy brides of christ wait they have to
be celibate when there are none yes but
yes once you take that last nun valve so
any woman could become a nun at any time
my friend actually what about men
i think priests do priests have to have
sex i actually have a friend okay i
won't name his name i actually wanna
name his name because this is and this
is like clerical celibacy is a
requirement in certain religions that
some are all members of the clergy be
unmarried
clerical celibacy also requires
abstention from deliberately indulging
in sexual thoughts and behavior outside
of marriage because these impulses are
regarded yeah if you're a priest you can
have nocturnal emissions that's that's
wild that's impossible you're going
biologically against your literal
chemistry biological like you can't
that's crazy you you mean to tell me
that no priest has a wandering thought
about something sexual
they have to and if they do they just
freak forgiveness i personally think
there is 100 a connection i don't know
what it is between all the you know
child sex things that happen with
priests and the fact that they have to
be celebration it's all suppression so
they're part of the intel community they
are all priests yeah priests are
interested in isis yeah yep um no
suppression network no surprise no
suppression network is where we're going
to put the merger allow
my friend was saying you know he's a
italian american guy
lives in brooklyn he said he said sex
with many hasidic jewish women
that's what he says and
nuns
right about there before right before
they're about to take their final vows
right before graduation they just want
to get a few late registration so he
said he would
google convince
yes member member and member in wedding
crash because i he told me this when we
saw the movie wedding crashes together
in wedding crashers when will farrell
goes like to funerals and all that he
goes i do something similar
he's like
milo
yeah yeah we went to applebee's after we
saw wedding crashers in fresh metal
shadow fresh meadows queens
and and and that's the word next to the
hooters right next to the hooters and we
went to the applebee's because the hudas
was too long of a wait so and and and
when we tried to get into hooters my
friend was going
so we could they wouldn't let us in
so so we go and then he says he goes you
know that that movie was great whatever
we're talking he goes i'm i've do
similar stuff that will film he said you
go to funerals to have sex with women he
goes no no he goes you know nuns a lot
of times nuns when they become nuns he
goes their vow of celibacy doesn't start
to the day they take
they you know they get the oath or
whatever so she's like if you go to like
where these nuns are like a week or two
before they all want to [ __ ] no that's
exactly what he said to me why have we
never heard of that i mean maybe he's a
genius oh my god he's had sex with
tbd nuns he said tbd nuns and multiple
hasidic jewish women he said you go to
the civic jews what does acidic jewish
women have to do because his whole thing
was like the more religious you are the
more you suppress it that's who he would
are they i said a jewish woman not
supposed to have sex no you can only
have sex with sick jewish men just like
my aunt who worked in a hospital in
brooklyn in a predominantly civic jewish
area said hasidic jewish men far and
away number one would come in with
sexually transmitted diseases because
they would have sex with prostitutes
they just hide it and pay actually so
that's the thing
they hide it they hide in one yeah
i don't know what i was doing with this
um
i'm like i know you got herpes under
your head
see look the secret sex lives of nuns no
this is a this is a thing that's out
there man breaking the habit that's what
the name of the article is oh my god i'm
gonna warn you this gets dark that's
dark okay well listen this is hay bay
this is what we do all right um
what uh where do we put on my readers
there you go it's not just lesbian love
nuns commonly fall in love with their
priests or parishioners we are all bound
by the vow of celibacy but we are also
guided by human nature
uh sex is a natural urge for women too
sure it is pope fr
pope francis admitted earlier this year
for the first time ever that the
clerical sexual abuse of nuns by priests
and bishops was a far bigger problem
than the church previously had conceived
what some sisters he said have been kept
as sex slaves suffering years of
unthinkable abuse incredible
no do you ever see that documentary on
netflix the keepers no the keepers it's
about it's watch it it's about the
baltimore
local baltimore
clergy
uh and the nun who gets killed um
murdered
the whole time she was being abused
sexually by these priests and the priest
was abusing kids and it was like a whole
abuse factory uh it's a documentary
called the keepers it's it's fascinating
i mean it's horrible but it's it's
interesting um in february the vatican
magazine women church world
published an expose that uncovered
hundreds of stories of none there's a
vatican magazine called women church
world war in church wcw
um
expose that uncovered hundreds of
stories of nuns being forced to have
abortions and in some cases secretly
raising their children in nunneries and
pretending they were orphans
buddy i'm telling you a nunnery y'all
don't know y'all don't know nothing you
all don't know there's a lot of stuff
that happens in in religious by the way
tt jerry go back one go back one thing
yeah
tt jerry continue
the entire editorial staff of the
magazine women church world uh quit a
few weeks after the issue came out
because what they described as
ambivalence about the problem among the
men of the church
yeah whoa
i know i've never i've never heard this
listen sometimes with religion no this
is not a blanket statement sometimes
with religion it's you know because of
this suppression like tt jerry told told
me when he was in prison i said what
group of people like would you know like
like i said with every prisoner you
serve time with her that you know you
knew of would eventually at least um one
would they always at least one time
engage in a sexual act one time he said
a big percentage of them yes at one
point in their prison sin if it was over
a certain amount of years they would
absolutely do because he said you just
it's human nature you just do it i said
who is the most he goes far and away the
muslims he goes the muslim
inmates would go to to gay sex acts
immediately and i was like really he
said every prison i went to that would
be that was the group that i would say
they did the most
sex stuff with guys muslims that's what
he's in prison i'm not saying outside
experience was that's what his
experience what do you think that is he
said this is his
he said because i think that
they have to suppress it so much on the
outside that on the inside but do they i
thought muslim men could be put like
polygamy could they
can you be polygamous
uh can you be a polygamous maybe i'm
wrong
i know i know mormons can i don't know
traditional sunni and shia islamic
martial jurisprudence allows muslim men
to be married to multiple women wow
that's not okay well also
aren't they promised like virgins in the
afterlife like a lot of them that's why
like your wife ever catch you cheating
you just go praise be to allah
willed it
that's what i would do i should have let
you know that uh yeah just last week i
converted i converted um
uh speaking of gay muslim sex super
massive black holes
speaking of gay muslim sex we're going
to be in nashville tomorrow night yes we
are
yes we are and i think there's still a
little bit of tickets left but that's
gay muslim sex yes we christy and i will
be at the ryman theater tomorrow night
babes that's what it is tomorrow it's
friday we're there at the rhyme it's
going to be a it's going to be a
humdinger of a show a muslim man and a
gay man
we open up it's it's like again it's a
social it's a social so it's a comedy
club but it really is a social it's a
social so we're gonna have fun there and
then uh yeah
and then you're going to chattanooga the
next day the next day saturday i'll be
this saturday i'll be in chattanooga lee
babes and then and that saturday i'll be
in the national predators game oh yeah
i'm gonna go look for him in bridgestone
look me in the bridge stone arena um i'm
pulling up to a bridgestone arena with
goodyear tires what can you do coinbase
you know me i use coinbase all the time
it's the only place i do my crypto stuff
i i love coinbase i look it on my phone
every day uh you know bitcoin's been a
little volatile right now but coinbase
has just come i just coinbase is the
best most user-friendly app i've tried
other cryptocurrency apps oh that's good
to know because i'm seriously i haven't
dabbled yet and i am crypto curious it
is it is listen sometimes we're all a
little crypto curious it's something
that we live through and i think
coinbase uh it lit i've checked all
these other apps truthfully it's the by
far the most user-friendly app you can
buy sell trade has all the up-to-date
coinbase uh uh uh crypto prices and
stuff and uh it's awesome i also i
didn't know this but they do offer
portfolio management and protection on
coinbase
that's huge yeah that's all you could
talk to somebody for me i have a very
diversified portfolio but it has yet to
have uh crypto in it right and i'm
looking to dip a toe now honestly if you
don't have a little bit of crypto
through coinbase base next week don't
even talk to me okay
uh coinbase overseas
coinbase offers if you don't if you know
what we're talking about you know you
know client base offers a trusted and
easy-to-use platform to buy sell and
spend cryptocurrency whether you're
looking to diversify just getting
started or searching for a better way to
access crypto markets start today with
coinbase for a limited time new users
can get ten dollars in free bitcoin when
you sign up today at coinbase.com hey
babe yeah sign up at coinbase.com hey
babe for ten dollars in free bitcoin
this offers for a limited time only so
be sure to sign up today and just go do
it go to coinbase.com because that ten
dollars in free bitcoin could literally
be worth a million dollars in five years
yeah you just don't know what the hell
if it explodes if you did this a few
years ago you would now own apple you
exactly yeah if you're carrying a credit
balance month after month it it can feel
like you're in a never-ending cycle of
debt with no end in sight upstart can
help you make that final payment so you
can get ahead uh whether it's paying off
credit cards consolidating high interest
debt or funding personal expenses
million people have used upstart to get
one fixed monthly payment with a clear
payoff debt rather than looking at
credit score alone upstart considers
other factors like your income current
employment and credit history to find
you a smarter rate for your loan find
out how upstart can lower your monthly
payment today when you go to upstart.com
hey babe that's upstart.com
hey babe don't forget to use our url to
let them know we sent you loan amounts
will be determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
providing your loan application
upstart.com
supermassive black holes will smash into
each other and warp space and time
scientists warn now pimp had a very
interesting theory he thinks that all
because the thing is with nuclear
weapons is yes we've dropped two nukes
on
japan right that happened that was the
only time in history but we've uh set
off so many nukes to detonation and
testing sites the nuclear energy pimp
feels could be warping space and time
and like
there's like he thinks like it's not all
like we're not in the right time right
now it's all got warped from the nukes
do we do we believe that this is like a
space time continuum there has to be
yeah there has to be there's quantum
mechanics you ever look at that
yeah can you explain it to me though
does anybody know what it is the space
time continuum or you can't even begin
to explain but it's it's it's just high
theory is it not or is it like but what
is it i don't understand so there's this
yeah what
explains i don't even know what do you
know what it is i i i have to brush up
on for sure okay so the space-time
continuum is because space consists by
the way homeless pimp if he puts himself
on camera he's dressed like peter pan um
and i like it peter
because space consists of three
dimensions and
time is one dimensional space-time must
therefore be a four-dimensional object
it is believed to be a continuum because
so far as we know there are no missing
points in space or instance in time and
both can be subdivided without any
apparent limit in size or duration so it
actually made me understand it less yeah
i was about to say i don't know what
what you just said i i'm actually went
backwards now because space consists of
three dimensions and time is one
dimension okay
that
there's four dimensions
therefore space space time must be
therefore a four dimensional object
is believed to be a continuum
well space is i mean time is continual
yeah i don't know this is above my pay
grade
something that breaks the space-time
continuum actually exists back to the
future
ish
and they are called black holes when
something gets sucked into a black hole
don't i know it just as it crosses the
even horizon isn't that supposed to be
the event horizon
[ __ ] idiots even horizon from an
external point of view time will stop
for that object okay
pimp do you get it
i don't understand what space or time is
a black hole is something where matter
and
and matter ceases to exist right like so
like you it's like you just dissolve i
guess it's just a dead zone i heard that
the key to
space exploration is using black holes
and wormholes and breaking space-time
continuum like that's what they think
advanced races
can do
this is a black hole here okay a black
hole
is a place in space where gravity pulls
so much that even light cannot get out
the gravity is so strong because matter
has been squeezed into a tiny space this
can happen when a star is dying because
no light can get out people can't see
black holes now my question is is the
black hole is a place in space where
gravity pulls so much that not even
light can get out do i still have to
wear a mask and do six feet distance
uh i mean depends on the region covert
is still very much a question mark got
it so i would say if you want to be
ultra careful mask up if you're going to
black feet even in the black hole yeah
you know what's something that's
interesting that like you know you know
me i love i love history and and you
know like the greatest thinkers like the
elon musks and stephen hawkins and you
know uh uh all these people are the
steve jobs of of the day tom green's the
tom
greens um
in in genius the kanye west
of our day
they like in the 13th and 14th century
those equivalents of those thinkers
thought the earth was flat yeah thought
um you know the the the sun revolved
around the earth and this was top stuff
yeah so they were dodo birds they were
dodo birds looking back so even our
thinkers now it's just the way it is
yeah a hundred two hundred years from
now they're gonna they're gonna be
dotable when lewis and clark when lewis
and clark you know the expedition in the
1800s thomas jefferson president tj was
the one who signed off on that they
believed because americans had never
been west of whatever it was ohio they
believe they truly in their hearts
believed they were going to find
dinosaurs when they went west that was
the president of the united states
thought that and he was not you know he
was a dodo bird to half the country yeah
what a goofball what a goofball so and
that wasn't that long ago that was like
200 years ago right so my thing is like
this quantum mechanics thing that we're
coming up but these this something may
be very explainable like they're going
to look at elon musk like what a
blubbering idiot yeah 200 years from now
wow isn't that crazy that is nutty yeah
it's nutty nutty when i start to
yeah when i start to think about this
stuff how does this have zero calories
and it's got and it tastes like a
tangerine and a wild strawberry tell me
how i think that they seriously let's
take a look tell me how how is it
possible how do they do it uh
ingredients carbonated mineral water
fine natural flavors what does that mean
though that's it because a strawberry a
strawberry has a calorie this says
tangerine and wild strawberry
it's it's it's i don't know how they do
it zero maybe there's not enough calorie
wow no calories i don't know
pellegrino essenza the italians figure
out a way yeah they do
that's my favorite uh this is the good
one yeah that's my favorite salsa by the
way no the pellegrino celsius and also
guys i've been forgetting to bring your
christmas presents in for months damn it
do you want him i have him with me yes
yeah all right hell yeah
uh anyway when i tell you i get crazy
crazy crazy crazy crazy depressed me too
i'm like we are just here for a blip a
blip we think the world revolves around
us it so doesn't and every time i
remember that i get sad and like we're
not gonna know our kids kids kids we're
gonna be like thinking back to the
history books we're gonna be nothing
we're gonna be a footnote in history if
that if that kids will never know this
world our kids kids kids yeah it's just
it's just it's terrible and also what is
it gonna be like like
we
life is gonna go on for so much longer
than we're here and we'll never get to
know the answers to what it was
merry christmas knowledge
of the future future right it's
depressing bring him in
here merry christmas with that on that
no
i love the bag here we go
[Music]
oh my god
it's uh
the photo of joe falling asleep dresses
it's a photo
it's a photo of jojo rosa falling asleep
at our at the halloween uh walk we did
the halloween parade it's hilarious and
because it's been in pimp's car so long
it smells like weed and vape
it's it's it smells yeah it smells like
a lens
that is this is classic pimp
wait and there's more
these glasses are sideways wow your kids
man oh my god as i was saying is that is
this the goosebumps god dude delilah is
gonna cry
what is this delilah's gonna lose her
freaking mind with that pull the string
on the back this is this is terrifying
what is this it's
a reference to goosebumps i thought it
scared the kids it would scare the well
tristan's gonna love it yeah
yeah look at that
and then sound in the pocket have some
pellegrino oh yeah he has a gift too in
the pocket of your hoodie okay
this is scary right here hold on i'll
get it out
[Music]
there you go
no
how did you get this
who made this the ikea bucket hat no
they sell it at ikea i don't know i
forget where it's from it is
they make it out of their own
out of their own bags i'm a big champion
of these bags yeah and they make did you
know they had a bucket hat i didn't know
i told you about these right yeah yeah
i like it dude how do you like me now
how you like me now oh my god i'm go i'm
taking a vacation today i'm bringing
this with me bring it with you no dude
that's perfect see pimp is a very
thoughtful guy this is dope thoughtful
christmas you're a very thoughtful
gift-giver as well thank you very much
you're a very thoughtful gift-giver and
pimp is a very thoughtful gift-giver i
am not i just throw money at you i throw
money at you
but i should be more thoughtful even
jazz is like you've got you know like i
know you're giving them a nice amount of
money but like you should just think
about something i'm like it makes me too
nervous because i think i'm gonna get
something wrong and i know money is
always right right that's true you can't
go wrong with money yeah yeah this is
did joe know about this
no oh that's so funny i was just hoping
you guys could show up for a sandwich
100
100 we are
yeah i love it we should put those up we
should put those up sleepy derosa sleepy
roses sleepy derozan let's just get him
up should we name my special sleepy
deroza
no i'm not joking those might sell like
gangbusters
see all them our solo wait today's march
10th yes so tomorrow at nashville in the
ryman all of our tabe merch will be
available for sale for the first time
ever for the first time
ever folks and then right after that
it's going up on the website this is my
solo stuff it's go to
salvocanocounty.com for this right now
amazing yeah but uh wow
we finally got the merch coming out dead
kanye west not he isn't dead but he
wrote a poem that said dead let's read
it and they put the new york post put an
article kanye west dead which is i mean
so
i want to punch him in the face yeah
that's tasteful but um it's not to say
listen can you zoom in
um i watched the kanye dock i finished
it later me too
that's something else that's something
else 20 20 years of access behind the
scenes like that yeah and i think and i
think you know because at first there
were parts of it i was like why do i
don't care even though i know she it's
great i don't care about cooties family
i don't care about cooties
i don't care about them at all it's like
it's beautiful beautiful life i get it
but it's like really just show me more
kanye yeah but by the third one i kind
of got it i was like you know this guy
was embarked on a documentary for him 20
years ago he barely sees them it's like
you know like he wanted to hey at least
if i can't get all this kanye footage
like i'll put my own family in it and
then it's you know nice that his father
was a photographer i liked it but the
first episode i was like i don't want i
don't need to see cootie's kids good
yeah
but i do like cookies i do like cookies
oh yeah i see they showed that that's
how we met d-ray davis at uh at the
laugh factory i think it was yeah yeah
cootie uh i do i did like start talking
like cootie after a while though yeah he
talks nice and slow i did yeah yeah like
kanye didn't know what he was gonna do
no just that's when we went to meet him
but he doesn't say like he says
kanye yeah yeah
he's like i guess that's what a man does
for his kids
years later i saw kanye and he was uh
you know i i just was like i was like
listening i'm like i wish cootie could
just read me the phone book cootie's the
best should we get cootie on the pond
let's see who do you have
you guys see that you know cootie and
the blowfish there you go kid cootie kid
yeah concordia who also was in the
documentary in the block that's cute
he was kid cudi
that uh before the documentary came out
kanye was demanding that they redo the
voiceover and drake does it
no no no he tried to demand it it didn't
play out well do you think cody and
kanye and i don't know how they got
terms um i don't know i don't know their
relationship what was your take away
from the doc was it pro co it was just
was it was it show all tell all and you
make your own decision was it in kanye's
favor was it like here's my honest i
think they just really showed it and you
can make up your own mind it was pretty
my honest opinion of it was is i i
really enjoyed it but i liked episode
one better than two better than three i
thought it got progressively worse yeah
um but maybe that's because
all the footage they had in two and
three most of which and two three stuff
i'd seen before so episode one was
amazing to see him what was amazing is
like seeing when he shows pharrell
through the wire and he genuinely runs
out of the room or lyrics to songs like
you know it all falls down and he's like
yeah and he's rapping and nobody cares
and you're like you almost want to be
like you idiots like this is like how do
you not understand but right that's a
very common thing it's like you know
people want to yell at like you know
gm's for oh how could you not draft
michael jordan first like you know
because you don't know right you know
what i mean like it's such a crapshoot
but with kanye i mean to me and again
maybe it's biased because i'm such a fan
of his i've always been a fan of kanye
west maybe it's because you know when i
was watching i was like how can you not
see that that's talent like i'm a
nothing
nobody i can see that he's talented and
doing things different because even the
what style of his rap he was never
rapping about drugs and violence and
girls his raps were about completely
different things and i'm like why don't
you want to take a chance on this guy
right right he's a visionary for sure
but i always like hannah too it is it is
crazy to see some of the footage now
because he it's like i don't know it's
i don't know who he has close to him
enough probably no one right that can
i don't know who his closest people are
because it does look like at times he
feels like
a little bit like lost man yeah when he
starts like getting into like this whole
thing it almost feels like he's so
isolated in his thoughts yeah that his
perception of reality is slightly warped
but then he toes the line between being
confident and a visionary and being like
listen to me you won't shut me you you
know you can't silence me which is all
well and good too but then it's like
there's this little this little turn and
then it's like he starts like kind of
talking about things that are very
disjointed and you're like well where is
he going with this right and it's like
you know it's just like he's talking
above everyone's heads like no i know
he's got a um he's got a didn't it feel
like real life entourage it felt like
entourage makes it look like it's fun
but this this is what it is yeah well
being that last one of the last scenes
of the show when kanye's like yo i have
the money i have everything he's like i
still am suicidal like he said he he was
like i thought it would go away i have
everything he said that he was like he
pushed everyone away he pushed everyone
he had to be on an island right
it's crazy man i know having almost like
what is he chasing anymore though
because like when he was younger you saw
what he was chasing and then he achieved
it achieved it achieved it he just then
it fashioned it cheated he achieved it
achieved it and now he's worth billions
of dollars he's at the very very very
very top it's like i don't know i was
like what else is there for him to chase
you know what i mean like
yeah i i agree and i you know i i found
myself at times being like you know
listen i'm just a big kanye fan so i i
liked him throughout but i could like i
was telling you i was watching it with
with jerry you know who did a lot of
time in prison he was like i'm telling
you i'm looking at this guy he's going
to wind up dead or in prison this guy
has got debtor in jail written all over
him i said he's a billionaire he goes
dead or in jail it's a mindset he kept
saying it's a mindset and he has it i
was like really interesting he goes
absolutely he goes the fact that he has
a god complex that's why everybody's in
prison thinks they're god really oh you
said that that's what it is everybody
thinks they're the [ __ ] in jail and they
were [ __ ] in jail that was like
interesting i hope that doesn't happen i
mean like literally he frames it he's a
vessel for the word of god but it also
feels like he
yeah is feels like he is like a savior
himself but like he might say himself
even like like it was cool like when is
that that scene in madison square garden
was doing the listening party for life
of pablo like all that stuff is like you
could just see like what a genius he is
like a genius and then he just goes on
these rants and spirals out yeah but
it's like on like i don't think it's you
can't really happen to all those
painters and [ __ ] and all those people
they do have mad geniuses in the past
like artists that would just i mean
cutting their ears off and stuff you
know and go baby yeah you guys want to
see his new player
oh
yeah
we did um on the whole thing yeah you
could see my review of it at youtube.com
christy comedy coming out next week we
did a whole review of it and it is
fascinating
i'm sorry so you can't get his album
anywhere but that little thing it's like
an nft yeah and it's in the shape of a
communion wafer
that's what that is
this looks more like an advil to me
so wait so
when the music is playing see those four
line uh lying yeah you can just play
with those and mute the parts of the
beaters the vocals oh it's actually
pretty dull it's pretty sick but i have
a question so does this have memory on
it and you could put other songs on it
you can and you could play around with
other artists songs but it only had
enough memory for one album at a time
i tried to put both of his albums on it
and it said only one album so how much
is this that was two hundred dollars
wait so this is a 200 player that only
holds one album at a time his album
comes pre-loaded yeah you could remove
it if you want yeah but it comes
pre-loaded so you're paying for the
album and this little player where his
singles will drop because he's left a
spotify and apple what do you mean where
they'll drop
you can only hear kanye's music from now
on on this but you mean that this is
connected to a service that you could
download his new stuff with this exact
one that's his patreon
right so when he releases a new song
okay he's gonna hit there unless he
wouldn't hit here how
they up they uploaded to the the website
where you have to like update your
player
oh okay so yeah so you're just taking it
off the internet it's an interface yeah
but i thought it had limited range it
only holds a certain amount so if he
drops a new song i have to delete
another song
that seems like they didn't think that
through that's stupid i like this cool
you could isolate like right just the
percussion just the just the bass just
the vocals and then you can also you
know chop and screw it and double speed
it slow it down
interesting and uh
this has been hey baby
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe